[Applause]
[Music]
so
that was a big night no not because cat
finally finished her snoopy jigsaw
puzzle
good job cat see a little perseverance
can pay off
wow
that went over well
all right but also the election for the
latest election count let's go to our
map
sorry about that let's go to the real
map
that's not wrong it's just incomplete
here's the actual map
finally an accurate count no fraud in
that one for sure
like they say virginia is for lovers but
what an amazing message sent by american
voters by now you've heard the
explanations parents had enough of
destructive racist wokism the
involuntary indoctrination of their kids
the ideological robotic brainwashed
forced in all facets of their lives not
to mention terry mcauliffe's robotic
dancing
thank you god bless you and let's go on
and forward
3.2 from the driveway of my house
my god
someone please check terry's medications
he has moves like jagger if mick were
having a series of strokes
he makes al gore look like jennifer
lopez
except instead of having a big ass he is
one
i haven't seen dance moves like this
since cat dropped a lit joint on her own
lap
but thankfully parents were basically
the opposite of brian stelter at a
buffet they were people who had enough
they were like harrison ford in the
movie witness a cop undercover as a
pacifist amish farmer only to be taunted
repeatedly by a guy who goes one step
too far
you're making a mistake
[Music]
[Laughter]
i love that scene that was america doing
the punching and that guy being punched
everything woke that's been shoved down
our throats
but my favorite part of last night other
than the magic mushrooms in the merlot
the joy from watching that incoherent
word regurgitator over at msnbc
collapsed into a heap of nonsensical
verbal puke
i watched glenn yonkin's interviews on
fox news and he did nothing that
claire's he did not
i mean he worshipped at the altar of
donald trump on fox news he flew an
insurrection flag at his rallies he
simply didn't he played dumb about a a a
zoom rally he did not really put much
distance between himself and donald
trump on the big lie or the deadly
insurrection in which police officers
were maimed by flagpole so
i think that the the real ominous thing
is that
critical race theory
which isn't real
turned the suburbs 15 points oh wow yeah
crt isn't real and weapons of mass
destruction was
how glorious was that implosion it was
like watching michael jackson set his
own hair on fire insurrection flags no
such thing as crt she's blurting out
talking points like a malfunctioning
stepford wife
if she got any more miserable she'd be
these low brain dipwads
this is now i think also the republican
playbook is is to use these issues to
scare people basically
um a feeling out of control you know
that that everything's out of control
with their children and they need to be
protected from these people with a
demagogues and this agenda right yeah
let's be clear some of it was dog
whistle yeah right some of it was
uh
dog whistle racism thousand percent she
took her
took her two times to figure it out so
what happened to these two i mean
mcauliffe might be break dancing but
these people are broken it's hilarious
powers is trying to sell a book called
grace while she sells lies about race
she really should get rid of the g in
the title if she's that desperate for
relevance as for brianna stick to what
you do best eating insects
are you ready cheers actually i'm less
scared of this okay
oh the crunch hmm
you have a wing hanging out of my mouth
you should
yeah she went from eating cicadas to
eating crow at this rate she'll be
snacking out of brian stelter's garbage
can
that's not a euphemism
but you see the grift
if you win it's about racism if you lose
it's about racism and for cnn it boils
down to denial they deny that their
obvious bitter loathing for most of
america spells their doom but don't feel
bad for these losers they relied on sex
pest scumquats over at the lincoln
project for commentary whose despicable
hoax of portraying parents as racists
blew up in their ugly faces
and now they're the ones in soot covered
blackface fact is the only expertise
lincoln project has is knowing the best
place to watch boys soccer practice
let's read up on that
[Laughter]
speaking of perv enablers where is rick
wilson or john weaver or steve schmidt
boy do they go silent somebody better
remove their shoelaces they're as done
as a bag of microwave popcorn cooked on
high for 45 minutes and they deserve it
after creating that tiki torch hoax
which was meant to destroy yunkan but
instead destroying the lives of a few
stupid democrat operatives they should
be shunned for life to call them scum is
an insult to everything currently living
on the rim of a public toilet
no offense andrew cuomo
now you keep hearing the phrase
bellwether that this election was a
canary in a coal mine but in reality we
were the canary for a year we were
chirping to anyone who listened that
wokism was racism and drag and it would
ultimately drag the terrified democrats
into the abyss but the dems don't watch
this show if they did they could have
seen this coming now they're as screwed
as a 12 hooker leaving hunter's room at
the motel 6.
why do cheap hooker lines always work
instead they listen to the clueless
creeps at cnn and msnbc and now you see
those dopes finally coming to grips with
their own dopeyness their dummy come
lately
you know the debate is among democrats
tomorrow is going to be you know the
same debate that that has been had now
for forever
the liberal wing is going to say well
you see what happens when we back from
our
principles and the monitors are going to
say they're we're just
there's it's too far to the left it's a
tedious debate the democrats are going
to have to come face to face with this
issue of locus you have a lot of people
saying oh he won
based on something that's not real that
doesn't exist
crt or wokism or whatever you want to
call it i can tell you
i mean that's all fair and
soft well their story changed faster
than biden in a vatican bathroom after
his little accident
because it's a remember that he pooped
himself
probably didn't happen but the joke
still works it's funny if we had said
any of that three weeks ago those chumps
would have called us racist but now they
know they bet on the wrong horse or
should i say horse's ass at this rate
they'll be approaching reality by 2044
when barron trump finishes his second
term
finally let's salute a real
groundbreaker winsome sears the first
woman of color to win a virginia
statewide election
and she did it as a republican
i'm telling you
that what you are looking at
is the
american
dream
the american dream i am not even first
generation american
when i joined the marine corps i was
still a jamaican but this country had
done so much for me i was willing
willing to die for this country usa
[Applause]
jamaican me hot
i don't know why i said that
anyway she is living proof but you
didn't hear about it on the view on cnn
or msnbc and why
would it be because she's a republican
well that's half of it the other half
she was black fact is the true racists
prefer their people of color to follow
one set of beliefs you leave that
plantation and you're dead to their
masters on cable news
which is the real story of this election
it exposed who the real racists are and
as predicted here on monday
last night they got their tiki torches
shoved right up their butts
let's welcome tonight's guest
he's a killer comedian literally he
moved to alaska and killed his career
comedian writer and actor jamie lasalle
the only beard in his life has appeared
on his face outspoken editor chief and
contributing editor to the spectator
chad with more
he's conquered books tv and podcasts and
next year he takes on puberty
the guy benson's show host
and fox's contributor guy benson
and she's like a remote hard to operate
too many buttons and you keep finding
her under the couch
fox's contributor catch him
jamie how's it going it's going great
how's alaska alaska is great uh it's
dark it's getting dark right now yeah
it's um it's dark that's where you see
movies where it's dark like 24 hours a
day and all this stuff and it's awful
and people go yeah but isn't it
beautiful and i go i don't know it's
dark
has it changed you at all i think it has
changed me you know i feel like i'm a
little bit tougher yes you know i'm a
little bit tougher yeah how so uh just
dude well can i bring this back to sears
yes okay
did you see the picture of her on
instagram with that machine gun
it was the ak i don't know what it was i
think it was an it was a gun we don't
know
and uh
but i saw that i don't know if these
guys saw but dude i saw this picture of
sears holding this machine gun ak-47 i
was like oh i cannot wait for the new
tarantino movie to come up
this is gonna be good but dude everyone
makes excuses but it's like the reason
things are turning the way they are is
people are tired of everything right
we're tired of all this stuff we're
right thanks for the one clap he um
no
i honestly thought it only deserved one
but because the the protocol's not
ruined everything you know what ruined
comedy yes like comedy was screwed and
even when we had shows they were weird
like i went to a show once and the
performer on stage wore a mask
the entire time he was on stage yeah and
it just kind of ruined you know he was a
ventriloquist
[Laughter]
or was he
[Laughter]
oh that was a two-parter
since i moved to alaska i got all two
parters
you got a lot of time in the dark
yes so guy uh what do you do you think
the democrats learned any lessons
from your keen mind
i think some of them who are more
rational and interested in winning might
learn some lessons but their base right
the activist class on twitter yeah the
people on msnbc and cnn most of them are
not learning anything they are doubling
and tripling down on calling everyone
stupid ignorant manipulated by
misinformation and racist right and it
worked out so well for them last night i
hope they go with that for the next year
i would welcome that i actually live in
virginia i voted excitedly for this
ticket republicans had not won any
statewide races for 12 years in virginia
then they swept last night and i will
say to your monologue i didn't think
that glenn younkin had this in him
because he's sort of like this
earnest suburban dad type guy in his
vest
he sent i read this today he sent a
fruit basket and thank you note to the
lincoln project
it was a troll of the trolls and i
applaud him that is a good move
god knows what they did to that fruit
i can think of a few things
chadwick how you doing over there i'm
great sir how are you i am fantastic
great what did you think of last night
what were your thoughts well two
questions what is an insurrectionist
flag yes did anyone catch what that is
yes um the dog whistle if america we're
told america is such a hateful racist
awful country
so racist you've got to send your racism
in morse code apparently with these dog
whistles that nobody knows what they're
talking about yes my big take though is
that this was not a referendum on
critical race theory i don't think that
you know susie jenkins with their three
kids in the suburbs in virginia still
even knows what it is right i think and
i think the reason why the liberal media
is focusing on that is because it was
actually on covet covered mandates
coveted panics especially where it
relates to the schools you know i think
that a bunch of parents were uh pissed
off that their kids were home for a year
and wanted revenge
the masking of the kids the mandates all
that but i don't think cnn can talk
about that because they still need
panic
but it's real
right yeah yeah
it is it is interesting uh cat all of
these things kind of came together and
it seems like the dems are on the wrong
side of everything but they can't
they they can't admit it right yeah i'm
not going to say that telling parents
they should not raise their kids and
that school should be government
indoctrination camps had nothing to do
with it
but a lot of the exit polls they said
you know it was economy was the top
issue and you said the gallup said 52
think that government's doing too much
so it's pretty clear people want smaller
government so of course they're going to
keep losing if they're what they look at
and they see well obviously it's because
they were being racist and america's
mostly racist i mean it's hard to i
don't know if they actually think that
or not because there's no evidence of
that yeah no i think it's i think what
happens is it is now just doctrine and
they have and they can't let go of it
it's it's part of their system and it's
going to ruin the party unless somebody
and somebody pulls the plug but i don't
see it i think they're just
they're they're barreling towards the
abyss and i couldn't be happier hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else